Misiles que se caen, cazas de combate que no
pueden disparar porque no tienen munición y
soldados alimentados con comida caducada...
alguno pensará que esto es el argumento de
una comedia estilo “Hot Shots” pero, en realidad,
estamos hablando de la invasión rusa de Ucrania.
Durante años, todos pensábamos que Rusia
tenía una industria de defensa envidiable. Sí,
es cierto, la economía rusa no es nada del
otro mundo. Hablamos de un país incapaz de
exportar productos de alto valor añadido como
coches, móviles o software... pero la industria
de defensa era la joya de la corona rusa. Para
que os hagáis una idea, Rusia tiene entre 2,5 y
3 millones de personas trabajando en fabricación
de armamento. Esto supone el 20% de los empleos
industriales de este país. En otras palabras:
parecía que el armamento era la excepción que
confirma la regla habitual en Rusia. La
única industria que realmente funcionaba.
Así nos lo mostraba Putin todos los años en los
desfiles militares. Todos los 9 de mayo, Rusia
celebra la victoria en la II Guerra Mundial (o,
como se dice en ruso, la “Gran Guerra Patriótica).
La Plaza Roja de Moscú se llena de gente para ver
el nuevo armamento de su ejército. Los increíbles
cazas Sukhoi Su 34 hacen acrobacias aéreas, los
modernos tanques Armata se pasean por las calles y
todos el mundo se estremece cuando Putin muestra
sus bombas nucleares delante del Kremlin. Sí,
amigos de VisualPolitik, todos pensábamos que
Rusia tenía músculo militar para poder tomar
Ucrania en cuestión de días. Sin embargo:
la forma de comprobar el poder militar de
un país no es un desfile sino una guerra. Y en
la invasión de Ucrania estamos viendo algo que
viene siendo norma habitual en la economía
rusa. Una cosa es lo que ves en “cuando
lo pides en Ali Express” y otra “la realidad”.
Oficiales de Estados Unidos aseguran que algunos
misiles rusos tienen una tasa de fallo del 60%
Sí, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
tras un mes de invasión en Ucrania, podemos
decirlo claro: el armamento ruso está muy
por detrás de las expectativas y el hype que
habían creado. Y esto es una sorpresa porque,
desde el año 2008, la principal prioridad de
Putin ha sido la modernización de su ejército.
Pensad que hablamos de un país que ha llegado
a gastar algunos años más del 5% de su PIB en
defensa: para que os hagáis una idea, Alemania
acaba de anunciar que va a gastar un 2% y nos
parece una medida histórica. En otras palabras:
Rusia ha puesto todos sus recursos en mejorar su
armamento. Es cierto que nadie se esperaba que el
arsenal ruso superase al de Estados Unidos. Pero,
comparado con cualquier otro país, incluRusia
parecía estar en la vanguardia militar.
Sin embargo, estamos viendo que ese
armamento es un auténtico desastre.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué? ¿Qué ha fallado
en la industria militar rusa? ¿Por qué,
pese a haber invertido tantísimo dinero,
Rusia mantiene un arsenal tan obsoleto?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes... ¿Os gusta la camiseta que llevo? Pues
es merchandising exclusivo de VisualPolitik... ¡Y
no está a la venta! La única forma de conseguir
nuestro merchandising es formando parte de
nuestra comunidad de PATREON. Si nos apoyáis en
Patreon no sólo podréis conseguir merchandising
sino que también recibiréis todas las semanas
nuestro boletín de análisis político además de
un montón de contenido adicional y de temas que
no podemos cubrir en los vídeos de VisualPoltik.
Si queréis disfrutar de todo este contenido, os
vemos en Patreon. Y ahora sí,
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
CAPITALISMO SIN EMPRESAS PRIVADAS
¿Cuál es el rifle de asalto más famoso del mundo?
¡Exacto! El AK-47, más conocido como KALASHNIKOV.
Como seguramente sabréis todo, el Kalashnikov es
de fabricación soviética. Con semejante icono de
la industria de defensa, muchos pensaréis que la
Unión Soviética tenía un sector armamentístico
de primera. Sin embargo... la realidad era muy
distinta. Si queréis conocer a fondo el armamento
soviético, os recomiendo que visitéis nuestro
canal hermano: MEGAPROJEKTS. En este canal hemos
sacado varios vídeos donde analizamos todos los
detalles técnicos de muchos de los grandes buques
insignia del ejército soviético: desde el mítico
caza Mig-29 hasta los submarinos de la clase
Typhoon. Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.
Pero, en resumen: casi todas las armas del
arsenal soviético se pueden resumir en un meme:
hay un mundo de diferencia entre “cuando lo pides
en el Ali Express soviético” y... cuando te llega.
La industria militar soviética estaba llena
de empresas estatales que no daban beneficios,
fábricas obsoletas y, sobre
todo, muchísima corrupción.
Veréis: en Estados Unidos, hay una
alianza entre gobierno y empresas
privadas. Os lo hemos contado varias veces en
VisualPolitik. Ahí está el ejemplo del F-35:
Washington necesitaba renovar su flota de cazas
de combate ¿Qué hicieron? Pues, a grandes rasgos,
hicieron un concurso donde se presentaron
varias empresas privadas. En este caso,
las principales candidatas eran BOEING y LOCKHEED
MARTIN. Finalmente, Lockheed Martin ganó el
concurso y se les adjudicó un contrato millonario.
Por supuesto, este sistema tiene sus problemas.
Las empresas privadas quieren maximizar su
beneficio. Eso explica la espiral de sobre costes
del F-35. Hablamos de más de 400.000 millones
de dólares que han salido del bolsillo del
contribuyente americano para engrosar la cuenta
de resultados de una empresa privada. Por supuesto
que este sistema tiene muchísimos aspectos que
podemos criticar. Pero, con todos sus problemas,
este sistema ha conseguido que las empresas
americanas sean capaces de desarrollar el
armamento más puntero del mundo. Es el resultado
de décadas de competencia entre empresas.
El comunismo soviético se basa en la idea
contraria: toda la economía dependía del
estado. La defensa se basaba en monopolios
estatales. Los resultados están a la vista.
Pero ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ¡Fonseca!
¡Hace 30 años que desapareció la Unión Soviética!
Rusia ha abandonado el comunismo. Y nadie en
su sano juicio diría que Vladimir Putin sea un
comunista convencido. Y sí, tenéis razón. Rusia
lleva décadas en un sistema que tiene muy poco
que ver con la revolución bolchevique.
Ahora bien: Rusia nunca ha abrazado el
capitalismo de libre mercado. Os lo hemos
contado mil veces en VisualPolitik, aunque
Rusia haya abandonado el comunismo hace décadas,
todavía mantiene una economía muy centralizada.
El estado sigue manteniendo un rol fundamental en
todas las industrias: y eso incluye, lógicamente,
el armamento. Y sí, tenéis razón. La pregunta
es ¿Dónde está el problema? ¿De verdad es tan
importante que las armas las fabriquen empresas
privadas? ¿Cómo se puede modernizar todo el
arsenal militar de un país sin competencia entre
empresas? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL PENSAMIENTO SILOVIKI
Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos: si
quieres que tus empresas sean competitivas,
lo mejor que puedes hacer es privatizarlas para
que compitan entre ellas ¿Verdad? Esto es lo que
diría la lógica económica liberal. Pero la Rusia
de Putin tiene una lógica muy distinta. Según
Vladimir Putin, el problema del comunismo no
era una economía centralizada sino una economía
basada en principios ideológicos. Es decir,
si quieres mejorar la eficiencia del sistema,
basta con cambiar a los directivos
y poner a tecnócratas al frente.
Tecnócratas que se han forjado en el seno de
la KGB y que tienen una mentalidad pragmática,
totalmente libre del romanticismo del comunismo o
de cualquier otra ideología. Este tipo de persona
tiene un nombre: “SILOVIKI”. Y por eso ¿Cuál
ha sido la receta de Putin para llevar a su
industria militar al siglo 21? Pues muy sencillo:
poner a silovikis en todos los puestos directivos.
Así es como, en el año 2007, nació ROSTEC,
un conglomerado de empresas diseñado para
ser el gran paraguas de la defensa rusa. Bajo este
paraguas están más de 700 empresas de armamento:
todas ellas propiedad del estado. Gracias
a agrupar empresas, se pueden eliminar un
montón de duplicidades. Todo ello siguiendo
criterios puramente tecnócratas. Por supuesto
¿Quién es el CEO de ROSTEC? Pues nada menos que
SERGEY CHEMEZOV, quien compañero de trabajo del
mismo Vladimir Putin cuando ambos estaban en
las oficinas de la KGB en Alemania de Este.
Dicho de otra forma, un SILOVIKI de manual.
Y diréis ¿De verdad Rostec ha servido para
eliminar costes? Pues lo cierto es que sí. Para
que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2008, todas
las empresas bajo el paraguas de ROSTEC sumaban
una plantilla de 788.000 trabajadores. En 2014,
se trataban de sólo 443.000 trabajadores. Desde
su fundación ROSTEC no ha dejado de absorber
todo tipo de empresas de armamento. Incluso
ha permitido que entre el capital privado en
algunas de las grandes armamentísticas rusas
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Pues os doy un ejemplo:
los fabricantes del mítico AK-47. El 74% de
JSC KALASHNIKOV CONCERN está en manos privadas.
Sin embargo, la expansión de ROSTEC tiene
un problema. Al adquirir más y más empresas,
ROSTEC ha terminado consolidando
aún más monopolios. Por ejemplo:
los cazas de combate. Estados Unidos trabaja con
4 grandes fabricantes: Boeing, Lockheed Martin,
Raytheon y Airbus (Airbus es europea pero
también tiene contratos con Washington). En
el caso de Rusia, prácticamente todos los
cazas de combate están fabricados por la
misma empresa: UAC que, por supuesto,
está debajo del paraguas de ROSTEC.
Y diréis ¿De verdad basta con colocar un
siloviki al frente de un monopolio para
hacer que sea más competitivo? Pues juzgad
por vosotros mismos. Otra de las grandes
empresas de defensa rusas es ALMAZ-ANTEY. Esta
empresa no depende de ROSTEC sino, directamente,
es propiedad del Ministerio de Finanzas Ruso. El
CEO de esta empresa es otro Siloviki de manual.
En este caso hablamos de VIKTOR IVANOV, ex
agente del KGB. Almaz-Antey es el gigante
donde se encuentra NPO Novator, el fabricante de
casi todos los misiles de precisión rusos. Sí,
justo esos misiles que están demostrando ser
tan defectuosos en la invasión de Ucrania. Y lo
cierto es que nada de esto es una gran sorpresa.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2017, NPO
Novator sólo podía producir 60 misiles KALIBR en
6 meses. Como os podéis imaginar, estas cifras son
ridículas si tenemos en cuenta que, en sólo un mes
de guerra, Rusia ha lanzado más de 1200 misiles.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero no hay ninguna
empresa privada en todo el complejo de
defensa ruso? Pues sí, lo cierto es que
hay alguna. Por ejemplo ¿Recordáis las
latas de comida caducadas que suministran
a los soldados del frente? Pues atentos.
Navalny desenmascara un cartel que,
supuestamente, ha ganado miles de
millones de rublos en contratos de defensa rusos
¡Adivinad de qué cartel estamos hablando! Exacto,
se trata de un entramado de empresas de
catering propiedad de YEVGENY PRIGOZHIN,
quien ¡Oh sorpresa! Es amigo personal de Putin.
Este buen señor es un cocinero propietario de
restaurantes y empresas de catering.
Según denunciaba Alexei Navalny,
Prigozhin trampeó todos los sistemas de
licitación públicas para convertirse en
el proveedor de comida del ejército. Hoy
en día, Navalny está en la cárcel y los
soldados rusos reciben latas de comida caducadas.
Y la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo muchos:
hemos dicho que la fábrica de misiles sólo era
capaz de producir 60 unidades de precisión en 6
meses. Sin embargo, Rusia ha lanzado más
de 1200 misiles en el campo de batalla:
¿Cómo es posible? ¿De dónde salen tantos
misiles? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a explicar.
TEORÍA VERSUS REALIDAD
La pregunta que todos los analistas militares se
hacen en este momento es... ¿Cómo es posible que
Rusia no haya sido capaz de lograr la supremacía
aérea? Es decir ¿Cómo es posible que Rusia no
haya sido capaz de destruir todas las defensas
antiaéreas de Ucrania, de tal forma que los cazas
rusos puedan bombardear sin problemas? Pensadlo
bien: Ucrania sólo tiene 134 cazas de combate,
y todos son de la época soviética. Rusia
tiene casi 1200 cazas, de los cuales,
300 están listos para atacar Ucrania. Hablamos,
además, de cazas de combate modernos. Recordad que
Rusia ha invertido miles de millones en modernizar
su ejército, y eso incluye la fuerza aérea. Ahí
tenemos, por ejemplo, los SUKHOI SU-34.
Estos cazas son unos bombarderos que se
empezaron a utilizar en el año 2008. Sobre
el papel, estos cazas de combate no tendrían
nada que envidiar a los F-15E de Estados
Unidos. Podríamos decir que son uno de
los mejores cazas de Rusia ¿El problema? El
problema es que a duras penas tienen munición
de precisión para disparar ¡Habéis oído bien!
Puede sonar ridículo. Pero todos los datos apuntan
a que Rusia no tiene suficiente munición de
precisión para esta guerra. Puede que os sorprenda
pero los misiles de precisión... ¡Caducan! Habéis
oído bien. Cada uno de esos misiles que dispara un
avión tiene una vida útil de entre 10 y 15 años.
Eso significa que, si quieres ir a la guerra,
más te vale que tus fábricas de armas estén
fabricando a pleno rendimiento. Sin embargo,
como ya hemos visto, las fábricas rusas
tienen un montón de problemas para producir
en masa ¿Conclusión? Pues estos Sukhoi Su-34 de
último modelo... han estado disparando munición
convencional. Lo que podríamos llamar “bombas
tontas”, es decir, que caen donde caen. Eso
explicaría noticias tan terribles como esta.
Tres muertos en un hospital de maternidad
bombardeado por un ataque aéreo ruso
Pensadlo bien: atacar un hospital de
maternidad no es sólo una atrocidad. También
es un fallo táctico. El objetivo de un ataque
es destruir las defensas enemigas. Matar niños
en un hospital, además de ser una salvajada,
no sirve ningún objetivo estratégico. Dicho
de otra forma: este ataque no es el fruto de
un general malvado que quiera matar niños. Es el
resultado de no tener misiles de precisión ¡Pero
no sólo hablamos de ataques mal planteados! Tener
pocos misiles de precisión plantea otro problema
a los aviones: les obliga a volar bajo. Y, como os
podéis imaginar, si un caza de combate vuela bajo,
se convierte en un objetivo fácil para
cualquier cañón antimisiles ¿Conclusión?
La Fuerza Aérea Rusa está perdiendo
sus mejores cazas en Ucrania
¡Exacto! Los mejores aviones de Rusia están
cayendo como moscas por no tener la munición
adecuada. Algo parecido ha ocurrido con los
tanques: Rusia ya ha perdido más 400 tanques en
esta guerra. Además, estamos viendo cómo incluso
la logística se realiza con camiones civiles. Todo
esto explica que la invasión de Ucrania nos
haya dejado imágenes tan cómicas como esta.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos:
¡A ver, Fonseca! ¿De verdad estás diciendo
que los rusos son tontos y se han ido
a una guerra sin municiones? Pues no:
el problema no es que los rusos sean tontos. El
problema es que un sistema político con malos
incentivos no genera otra cosa que fracasos.
Lo hemos dicho más veces en VisualPolitik,
la economía rusa está pensada para que ninguna
empresa pueda salirse del control de Putin y sus
élites. En ese sentido, Rusia es totalmente
eficaz. Ahora bien, a la hora de innovar,
los silovikis son incapaces de generar resultados.
Así que una vez más nos volvemos a encontrar con
que hay un océano de diferencia entre cuando
lo pides en el Aliexpress Siloviki y cuando te
llega. Y lo cierto es que no es la primera vez.
¿Recordáis la vacuna rusa contra el coronavirus?
¿La famosa Sputnik V? Sobre el papel, la vacuna
funcionaba. Es decir, el diseño y la fórmula eran
correctos. No sé si lo recordaréis, pero, en
aquel momento, hubo un debate mundial sobre la
efectividad de la vacuna rusa. Por cierto, que
en VisualPolitik le dedicamos un vídeo por si
lo queréis echar un vistazo. Hoy en día, ya nadie
ha vuelto hablar de esta vacuna... y ni siquiera
está aprobada por la OMS. Dicho de otra forma, que
es muy probable que, con la industria de defensa
soviética esté llena de casos como el de la vacuna
Sputnik V. Hablamos de cazas de combate que,
sobre el plano, son un prodigio tecnológico pero
que no tienen munición. Tanques de último modelo
que no se pueden producir en masa porque no hay
fábricas disponibles. Misiles de precisión que
no son tan precisos como parecía. Y así, un suma
y sigue de proyectos fracasados. Durante años,
el entorno de Putin los ha estado ocultando.
Pero ahora que estamos viendo la eficacia de
estas armas en el campo de batalla, estamos viendo
que todas las suposiciones que teníamos sobre la
economía rusa son ciertas. Ahora sólo queda una
incógnita en el aire... y os la dejo para que la
respondáis en los comentarios ¿Qué pasa con el
armamento nuclear ruso? Todos sabemos que Rusia
tiene el mayor arsenal nuclear del mundo. Putin
ha llegado a amenazar con utilizarlo. La pregunta
es ¿De verdad funciona? ¿Y si buena parte de
esas cabezas nucleares estuvieran caducadas?
¿De verdad esos misiles intercontinentales son
tan efectivos como asegura el Kremlin? ¡Por
supuesto! Ninguno queremos comprobarlo pero...
¿Qué pensáis? ¿Será otro hype de Rusia? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios. Como
siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik,
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta el próximo vídeo.